IN VAIN.
WE WILL SECURE OUR BORDERS.
>> Juan: MUCH MORE ON THAT
LATER IN THE SHOW.
FIRST, WE WANT TO REMEMBER A
LEGEND AND A FRIEND.
DR. CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER WHO
PASSED AWAY YESTERDAY AT THE
AGE OF 68 AFTER A BATTLE
WITH CANCER.
>> THE BIG ESTHERER THAT WE
MAKE IS TO LOSE THE DAMN WAR
BECAUSE WE REFUSE TO
RECOGNIZE WHO THE ENEMY IS
AND WHAT IT REQUIRES.
FOR GOD'S SAKE WHY DO YOU
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
THE MOURNING IS OVER, THE
CHIVA IS DONE.
IF YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE
YOU SHOULD BE OPTIMISTIC.
>> I THINK IT WILL SNOW IN
HELL BEFORE THE DOJ IS GOING
TO GO AFTER HER.
WE ALL WERE EXPECTING IT.
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
THAT WAS THE DOG THAT DIDN'T
BARK.
>> Juan: CHARLES WAS THE
LEADING CONSERVATIVE THINKER
OF HIS GENERATION TO MANY.
HE TOUCHED SOME OF OUR LIVES
RIGHT HERE AT THE FOX NEWS
CHANNEL.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, I OFTEN
FOUND MYSELF ON THE OPPOSITE
END OF THE OPINION FENCE
FROM KRAUTHAMMER.
THAT WAS THE CASE FOR JUST
ABOUT A DECADE ON "SPECIAL
REPORT."
CHARLES WAS ALSO, LIKE ME, A
HUGE BASEBALL FAN.
AND LAST NIGHT CHARLES WAS
HONORED AT NATIONALS PARK IN
D.C.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF
FOX ASK ME ABOUT CHARLES.
I THINK IT'S VERY HARD
SOMETIMES TO EXPLAIN TO THEM
HOW HE TOUCHED SO MANY OF
US.
HOW COULD ALL YOU GUYS KNOW
HIM?
BUT JESSE HAD A VERY SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP.
JESSE, EXPLAIN.
>> WELL, I WAS THE PRODUCER
FOR THE O'REILLY FACTOR FOR
MANY YEARS AND IT WAS MY
GREAT HONOR TO PRODUCE
EXRAWT FOR ABOUT FIVE OF
THOSE YEARS.
SO ONCE A WEEK I WOULD GET
ON THE PHONE WITH
DR. KRAUTHAMMER AND I WOULD
TRIBE
TRANE
TRANSCRIBE POINTS ABOUT BILL
TOPICS FOR THAT NIGHT.
I WOULD ABSORB THE TALKING
POINTS AND GO TO THE BAR
LATER AND REPEAT THEM AS IF
THEY WERE MY OWN.
[LAUGHTER]
TO SOUND SMART.
I LOVED DOING IT I ALSO
REMEMBER FOR YEARS I WOULD
DVR "SPECIAL REPORT."
AND THEN I WOULD FAST
FORWARD TO THE ALL-STAR
PANEL AT THE END.
FAST FORWARD THROUGH YOU, NO
OFFENSE.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THEN I WOULD JUST LISTEN
TO CHAMPLETS THE DIFFERENCE
WITH CHARLES COMPARED TO ANY
OTHER COMMENTATOR WHEN HE
SPOKE, EVERYTHING WENT
QUIET.
AND YOU LISTENED.
AND YOU NEVER INTERRUPTED
CHARLES.
NOT EVEN O'REILLY
INTERRUPTED CHARLES.
AND THAT'S A PRETTY TALL
ORDER.
EVEN MY LIBERAL MOTHER LIKED
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER BECAUSE
HE HAD A WAY ABOUT HIM.
HE WAS SO RATIONAL AND
RESPECTFUL.
HE WAS NEVER DISAGREEABLE.
YOU COULD ALWAYS KIND OF AS
A LIBERAL DISAGREE WITH HIM
BUT NOT HATE HIM AND HE WAS
NEVER EVER ATTACKED IF YOU
EVER REALIZED FROM THE LEFT.
AND IT SHOWS THE KIND OF THE
DEPTH OF HIS POWER BECAUSE
HE WAS HONORED BY GEORGE W.
BUSH, THE NATIONALS,
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU.
I HAD FRIENDS TEXTING ME
RANDOMLY I'M SO SORRY TO
HEAR ABOUT CHARLES.
HE HAD SUCH A GREAT IMPACT.
I REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME I
MET HIM FACE TO FACE.
I WAS IN THE D.C. BUREAU AND
JUST COME BACK FROM ONE OF
THOSE CRAZY WATTERS WORLDS I
WAS COCKY AND ROLLED INTO
THE GREEN ROOM AND CHARLES
IN THAT LOW TONE JESSE,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING MY TO BE IN YOUR
WORLD.
AND HE SAID IT WITH A WINK
AND A SMILE.
IT JUST REALLY MADE ME
LAUGH.
>> Juan: KENNEDY, WE WERE IN
THE GREEN ROOM AND YOU SAID
SOMETHING ABOUT WHAT CHARLES
MEANT TO YOU THAT REALLY
CAUGHT ME BY SURPRISE.
I WAS TAKEN BY IT.
IT WAS WONDERFUL.
>> THERE IS SOMETHING SO
INCREDIBLY POSITIVE ABOUT
WHAT HE DID WHICH WAS HE
OPENED A WINDOW OF MOURNING
AND LET PEOPLE IN ON THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT HE DID NOT
HAVE LONG LEFT IN THIS
WORLD.
AND THERE'S SOMETHING SO
SWEET AND HONORABLE ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, THE ONLY TIME WE
REALLY TALK ABOUT PEOPLE IN
THESE GLOWING TERMS IS AFTER
THEY PASS.
IF YOU ACTUALLY ALLOW
SOMEONE IN TO THE END OF
YOUR LIFE, SO THEY CAN
CELEBRATE YOU, AND LET YOU
KNOW WHAT HAVE YOU MEANT TO
THEM WHILE YOU ARE STILL
LIVING, THAT IS SO
INCREDIBLY PROFOUND AND IT
IS SUCH AN AMAZING GIFT THAT
VERY FEW PEOPLE ARE CAPABLE
OF GIVING SO MANY PEOPLE AND
HE WAS ABLE TO DO THAT.
HE HAD THE CONFIDENCE AND HE
HAD ENOUGH RESPECT FOR
HIMSELF, HIS AUDIENCE AND
HIS VERY CLOSE FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES HERE AT FOX.
AND I THINK WE WILL BE
FOREVER GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
NOT ONLY FOR SO MANY PEOPLE
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REACH OUT TO HIM, BUT ALSO
AS AN EXAMPLE TO OTHER
PEOPLE THAT YOU CAN TAKE
THIS ON WITH A DEGREE OF POT
OF AND COMPORTMENT THAT WE
REALLY SEE AND I HOPE THAT
PEOPLE SEE THAT AS AN
EXAMPLE AND NOT ASHAMED TO
PASSING ONTO THE NEXT REALM.
AS PEOPLE OF FAITH AND THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE OF FAITH
HERE, WE EMBRACE THE AFTER
LIFE.
WE ARE TERRIFIED OF DYING.
SUCH BRAVERY AND STRENGTH
THAT CHARLES SHOWED GOING
INTO THAT.
>> Juan: I ALWAYS THOUGHT
AND THE REASON YOUR WORDS
TOUCHED ME IS I ALWAYS
THOUGHT THE IDEA OF SOMEONE
WHO WAS PARALYZED AND LIVING
IN A WHEELCHAIR, FOR HIM TO
DO JUST WHAT WE DO TO COME
AND BE COMMENTATORS ON
TELEVISION, TO WRITE A
COLUMN, BOY, HE WAS TERRIFIC
ABOUT IT.
HE NEVER WAS SELF-PITYING.
>> Greg: HE HAD TO FACE
SOMETHING EVERY DAY THAT WAS
BEYOND HIS OWN DISABILITY.
IT WAS PEOPLE THAT HE MET
THAT WEREN'T AWARE THAT HE
WAS DISABLED UNTIL THEY MET
HIM.
AND BECAUSE HE ALWAYS WHEN
HE WAS SHOT AT FOX YOU COULD
TELL HE WASN'T
TELL HE WAS IT
TELL HE WAS IN A WHEELCHAIR.
WHEN YOU MEET HIM MAYBE YOU
DIDN'T KNOW AND I REMEMBER
ONE OF MY -- ONE OF MY
BUDDIES MADE JOKE ABOUT
SHOULD CHARLES GO ON
"DANCING WITH THE STARS."
I SAID YOU WERE SUCH AN
A-HOLE.
HE HAD NO IDEA.
IS HE A HUGE FAN.
IT WAS AFTER TUCKER WAS ON.
HE HAD NO IDEA THAT CHARLES
KRAUTHAMMER WAS IN A
WHEELCHAIR.
SEA VERY SERIOUS DUDE.
IS HE VERY FUNNY.
ONE THING THAT WAS
INTERESTING ABOUT HIM IS
THAT HE NEVER LET THIS --
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO HIM IN
HIS LIFE ACTUALLY AFFECT HIM
AND IN A WEIRD WAY IT TURNED
INTO AN ASSET FOR HIM
BECAUSE IT MADE HIM A MAN OF
IDEAS BECAUSE HE WAS
LIMITED -- HE WAS IN A CHAIR
FOR HIS ENTIRE LIFE.
AND HE MADE HIS ACHIEVEMENT
COME FROM HERE.
EVERYTHING WAS ABOUT IDEAS.
AND THE OTHER THING I WOULD
JUST MENTION IS WE DO LIVE
IN A TIME WHERE MORE PEOPLE
ARE HEALTHY AND LIVE LONGER
AND LESS DISEASE AND LESS
POVERTY.
WE HAVE AN INCREASE IN
SUICIDES.
WE SEE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DEALING WITH INNER DEMONS.
I THINK THAT'S WHY HE IS SO
INSPIRATIONAL BECAUSE HE HAS
EVERY EXCUSE TO HATE LIFE.
HE EMBRACED IT I DO NOT
THINK I COULD THAT MAN.
I HONESTLY DO NOT THINK I
COULD BE 10% OF CHARLES
KRAUTHAMMER.
>> Juan: THAT'S THE
DEFINITION OF COURAGE WHEN
PEOPLE STAND UP IN DIRE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
CANDACE, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
CAN CAN EXACTLY EVERYTHING
THAT YOU SAID HERE, DESPITE
HIS DISABILITY HE WILL BE
REMEMBERED AS A MAN OF GREAT
FORTITUDE.
VIRTUE.
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
POLITICAL AISLE COMING
FORWARD AND HONORING THIS
MAN SHOWS YOU HE WAS PATTERN
OF TREMENDOUS CHARACTER.
LOOK, HE WAS HAPPY WITH HIS
LIFE.
I THINK THAT THAT'S THE MOST
WONDERFUL THING.
THE WONDERFUL TAKE AWAY HERE
IS HOW HAPPY AND CONTENT HE
WAS WITH THE LIFE THAT HE
LIVED.
>> INTERESTING FOR ME
BECAUSE I KNEW HIM FOR SO
LONG.
I KNEW HIM BEFORE FOX EVEN.
I WILL SAY TWO THINGS ABOUT
CHARLES.
ONE IS THAT THE SENSE OF
SPIRIT AND HUMAN KINDNESS
THAT CAME FROM CHARLES
KRAUTHAMMER WAS NO PRETEND.
YOU INTRODUCE HIM TO PEOPLE
AT FOX.
OH, CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER.
AND HE WOULD BE LIKE
CRACKING JOKES AND OPEN WITH
SO MANY FOLKS, JUST VERY
WARM.
BY THE WAY, JESSE, GOING TO
A BASEBALL GAME WITH CHARLES
WAS, LITERALLY PEOPLE COMING
UP TO HIM.
BECAUSE HE GAVE STRUCTURE TO
SO MUCH CONSERVATIVE
THOUGHT.
A LOT OF CONSERVATIVES FELT
HEY, THIS IS THE GUY.
THIS IS THE INTELLECTUAL
THAT IS ABLE TO FRAME
CONSERVATIVE THOUGHT IN SUCH
A WAY THAT THE LIBERALS AND
THE LEFT HAS TROUBLE WITH IT
THAT THEY FINALLY FEEL THAT
HERE IS AN INTELLECTUAL OF
THE RIGHT.
SOME PEOPLE CALL THEM NEO
CONSERVATIVES.
IT WAS CHARLES WHO TALKED
ABOUT THE REAGAN DOCTRINE IN
TERMS OF AMERICA GLOBALLY
STANDING UP FOR FREEDOM.
FOR SECURITY.
HE TALKED ABOUT A BUSH
DOCTRINE IN TERMS OF GOING
IN TO WAR.
HE GAVE THE FRAMEWORK.
AND GOING TO BASEBALL,
JESSE, WITH HIM, NOT ONLY
DID YOU SEE THE PEOPLE WERE
THANKING HIM FOR DOING THAT
YOU LEARN THAT THE LEARNERS
WHO OWN THE WASHINGTON
NATIONALS LOVE CHARLES.
HERE WE ARE YOU GO IN
CHARLES SPECIALLY MADE VAN
GOING DOWN SOUTH CAPITAL
STREET AND HERE WE ARE.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT PICTURE AGAIN, THAT'S
CHARLES ON THE BIG SCREEN
OVER THE STADIUM LAST NIGHT
AS THE NATS WERE PLAYING THE
ORIOLES AND THERE WAS A
MOMENT OF SILENCE.
IF YOU DROVE AND YOU THINK
OH MY GOD IS THIS GUY GOING
TO CRASH THIS VAN?
BUT YOU GET TO NATIONALS
PARK AND HE HAD THE BEST
PARKING LOT, JESSE BECAUSE
THE LEARNERS HAD A PARKING
SPOT FOR HIM IN THE STADIUM.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT GEE, HOW'S
COME I CAN'T GET THIS.
>> Greg: JESSE WANTS TO GIVE
A VAN.
I KNOW A FEW PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DRIVEN WITH CHARLES AND IT
WAS ONE OF THE MOST
FRIGHTENING.
>> CHARLES DRIVING?
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE ARE
AWARE OF THAT SAY A VAN.
ASSUMPTION MAYBE SOMEBODY IS
DRIVING.
NO, NO.
HE IS DRIVING IT.
>> Juan: SPECIALLY EQUIPPED
VAN.
I USED TO JOKE THE MOST
EXPENSIVE CAR IN THE FOX
PARKING LOT DIDN'T BELONG TO
BRET OR BRIT HUME OR ANYBODY
IT BELONGED TO CHARLES
KRAUTHAMMER.
KENNEDY THOUGH, YOU REALLY
THINK HE WAS A MAN OF
PERSONIFICATION OF COURAGE.
>> Kennedy: ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT AN INCREDIBLE EXAMPLE.
AND I DO HOPE THAT IN
ADDITION TO SOME OF THE
WRITING AND THE PHILOSOPHY
THAT HE ENVIEWED IN HIS
WRITING PEOPLE ALSO TAKE
AWAIT INCREDIBLE LESSON AT